Kelsey just touched on
a really important concept for
designing scalable applications,
twelve-factor apps.
You can think of the twelve
factors as best-practices for
designing modern applications that
fit three really important criteria.
Portability, deployability and
scalability.
Twelve-factor applications are designed
to be portable, because they
focus on eliminating elements that
vary between execution environments,
like dependencies and configuration.
Not only that, but twelve-factor
applications are designed to be deployed
on cloud platforms, like GCP,
AWS, and by focusing on
keeping production in development
environments close to uniform.
We can start continuously
deploying our applications,
meaning we can set up tooling to roll
out updates to code very quickly.
Finally, if we follow these principles
when building our applications,
they'll be able to scale up to reach
our users' demands, while using most of
the same toolings and practices
we've been employing from the start.
Now, Kelsey touched on a few of
the twelve-factors earlier and
how our application handles them,
but there's a lot more.
The ones we didn't handle
directly in our application,
we use higher level tools for later.
As you can see, when it comes to
deploying apps that scale into
the cloud, writing twelve-factor
apps helps us reach that goal.